Yogi Berra
a US baseball player and philosopher
said if we don't know where we're going
we might not get there accumulating
scientific knowledge is giving us
greater insights greater clarity into
what our future might look like in a
changing climate and what that could
mean for our health I'm here to talk
about a related aspect on how our
emissions of greenhouse gases from
burning of fossil fuels is reducing the
nutritional quality of our food we'll
start with the food pyramid you all know
the food pyramid we all need to eat a
balanced diet we need to get proteins we
need to get micronutrients we need to
get vitamins and so this is a way for us
to think about how to make sure we get
what we need every day so we can grow
and thrive but we eat not just because
we need to we also eat for enjoyment
bread pasta pizza there's a whole range
of foods that are culturally important
we enjoy eating these and so they're
important for our diet but they're also
important for our culture's carbon
dioxide has been increasing since the
start of the Industrial Revolution
increasing from about 280 parts per
million to over 410 today and it
continues to increase the carbon that
plants need to grow comes from this
carbon dioxide they bring it into the
plant they break it apart into the
carbon itself and they use that to grow
they also need nutrients from the soil
and so yes carbon dioxide is plant food
and this should be good news of rising
carbon dioxide concentrations for food
security around the world making sure
that people get enough to eat every day
about 820 million people in the world
don't get enough to eat every day so
there's a fair amount written about how
higher co2 is going to help with our
food security problem we need to
accelerate our progress in agricultural
productivity to feed the 9 to 10 billion
people who will be alive in 2050 and to
achieve the sustainable development
goals particularly the goal number two
that is on reducing food and security
increasing nutrition increasing access
to the foods that we need for everyone
we know that climate change is affecting
agricultural productivity the earth has
warmed about 1 degree centigrade since
pre-industrial times that is changing
local temperature and precipitation
patterns and that has consequences for
the agricultural productivity in many
parts of the world and it's not just
local changes in temperature and
precipitation it's the extremes extremes
in terms of heat waves floods and
droughts are significantly affecting
productivity and that carbon dioxide
besides making plants grow has other
consequences as well that plants when
they have higher carbon dioxide increase
the synthesis of carbohydrates sugars
and starches and they decrease the
concentrations of protein and critical
nutrients and this is very important for
how we think about food security going
forward a couple of nights ago in the
table talks on climate change someone
said that there are five seventh
optimist that there are an optimist five
days of the week and this is a topic for
the other two days when we think about
micronutrients almost all of them are be
affected by higher co2 concentrations
two in particular are iron and zinc when
you don't have enough iron you can
develop iron deficiency anemia is
associated with fatigue shortness of
breath and some fairly serious
consequences as well when you don't have
enough zing
you can have a loss of appetite it is a
significant problem around the world
there's about 1 billion people who are
zinc deficient it's very important for
maternal and child health it affects
development the B vitamins are critical
for a whole range of reasons they help
convert our food and energy they're
important for the functions of many of
the physiologic activities in our bodies
and when you have higher carbon in a
plant you have less nitrogen and you
have less B vitamins and it's not just
us cattle are already being affected
because the quality of their forage is
declining in fact this affects every
consumer of plants and give a thought to
for example our pet cats and dogs if you
look on the label of most of the pet and
dog food there's a significant amount of
grain in those foods so this affects
everyone how do we know that this is a
problem we know from field studies and
we know from experimental studies and
laboratories in the field studies and
I'll focus primarily on wheat and on
rice there's fields for example of rice
that are divided into different plots
and the plots are all the same the soil
is the same the precipitation is the
same everything is the same except
carbon dioxide is blown over some of the
plots and so you can compare what it
looks like under today's conditions and
under carbon dioxide conditions later in
the century I was part of one of the few
studies that have done this we looked at
18 rice lines in China and in Japan and
grew them under conditions that you
would expect later in the century and
when you look at the results the white
bar is today's conditions the red bar is
conditions later in the century so
protein declines about 10 percent iron
about 8 percent zinc about 5 percent
these don't sound like really big
changes
but when you start thinking about the
poor in every country who primarily eat
starch that this will put people who are
on the edge over the edge into franc
deficiencies creating all kinds of
health problems the situation is more
significant for the B vitamins when you
look at B vitamin b1 and vitamin b2
there's about a 17 percent decline
pantothenic acid vitamin b5 is about a
13 percent decline and folate is about a
30 percent decline and these are
averages over the various experiments
that were done folate is critical for
child development pregnant women who
don't get enough folate or at much
higher risk of having babies with birth
defects so these are very serious
potential consequences for our health as
co2 continues to rise in another example
this is modeling work that was done by
Chris Wyant and his colleagues taking a
look at this chain from higher co2 to
lower iron and zinc and they only looked
at iron and zinc to various health
outcomes and they looked at malaria die
real disease pneumonia iron deficiency
anemia and looked at what the
consequences could be in 2050 and the
darker the color in this the larger the
consequences so you can see the major
impacts in Asia and in Africa but also
note that countries such as the United
States and countries in Europe the
populations also could be affected they
estimated about a hundred and 25 million
people could be affected
they also modeled what would be the most
effective interventions and their
conclusion was reducing our greenhouse
gases getting our greenhouse gas
emissions down by mid-century so we
don't have to worry so much about these
consequences later in the century these
experiments these modeling studies did
not take climate change itself into
account they just focused on the carbon
dioxide component so when you put the
two together it's expected the impact is
much
to larger and the one I've told you I'd
love to be able to tell you right now
how much the food you had for breakfast
the food you're going to have for lunch
has shifted from what your grandparents
ate in terms of its nutritional quality
but I can't we don't have the research
on that I'd love to tell you how much
current food insecurity is affected by
these changes but I can't we don't have
the research on that either there's a
lot that needs to be known in this area
including what the possible solutions
could be we don't know exactly what
those solutions are but we've got a
range of options
we've got advancements in technologies
we've got plant breeding
we've got biofortification soils could
make a difference and of course will be
very helpful to know how these changes
could affect our future health and the
health of our children and the health of
our grandchildren and these investments
take time it will take time to sort all
of these issues out there is no national
entity or or business group that's
funding this research we need these
investments critically so that we do
know where we're going in the meantime
what we can do is ensure that all people
have access to a complete diet not just
those in the wealthy parts of the world
but everywhere in the world we also
individually and collectively need to
reduce our greenhouse gas emissions to
reduce the challenges that will come
later in the century it's been said that
if you think education is expensive try
ignorance let's not let's invest in
ourselves in our children and in our
planet thank you
[Applause]